ما نشاهده في هذه الحرب التي تدور رحاها
بين روسيا واوكرانيا هو دليل اضافي يدفع
باتجاه السعي للحصول على طائرات من الجيل
الجديد ويبدو ان روسيا عمدت الى استخدام
الطائرات المقاتله من الجيل الرابع التي
تحلق على ارتفاع المنخفض لتجنب الصواريخ
الاوكرانيه من طراز 300 وهو ما يجعلها
عرضه للاصابه بصوارخ فعاله ضد اهداف
ارتفاعات المنخفضه مثل صواريخ ستينجر
[موسيقى]
اما بالنسبه للطائرات من الجيل الرابع فهي
تمثل خطرا اكبر من حيث رصد هذه الطائرات
واعتراضها بصواريخ ارض جو تعود لحكمه
الحرب البارده لذلك فان القاذفات تصاحب
مهمه رصدها وتحلق لفترات اطول وسترى
بالتاكيد المزيد من الاستثمارات تدخل في
الاجيال المقبله من الطائرات الحربيه سواء
كانت من الجيل الخامس او السادس
[موسيقى]